حرب التحقيقات والتحقيقات المضاده بين
الديمقراطيين والجمهوريين في الولايات
المتحده لا تكاد تضع اوزارها حتى تشتعل من
جديد على ايقاعات رئاسيه العام المقبل
لجنه الرقابه في مجلس وبالامريكي اصدرت
مذكرات استدعاء رؤساء بنوك وشركات للتحقيق
بسجلات ماليه تخص عائله الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن ونجله
استدعت بنك اوف امريكا وكثي بانك وجيبي
مورجان
الى
الشريك التجاري السابق لنجل ساكن البيت
الابيض هانتر بايدن لطلب السجلات الماليه
النائب جيميراسكين وهو العضو الديمقراطي
الاعلى في لجنه الرقابه اشتكى من ان رئيس
اللجنه جيمس كومر الجمهوري من كنتاكي كان
يحاول اخفاء المعلومات المتعلقه بالتحقيق
من الديمقراطيين لجنه الرقابه في مجلس
النواب طلبت مساعده هانتر بايدن عبر
الادلاء بشهادته امامها مستشهده بالوثائق
الماليه التي تم الاستدعاء اليها وثائق
تظهر انه حول اكثر من مليون دولار الى
افراد عائله بايدن بعد تلقيه ثلاثه ملايين
دولار من شركه طاقه صينيه في عام 2017
فالى اين يصير قطار صراع التحقيقات بين
الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين في الولايات
المتحده بلال البشتين العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات